All right, reminder of what we're called to do, walk worthy of God, the fully pleasing
to Him, bear fruit in all good works, grow in the knowledge of God, some priests who
presumes that we are studying His word to know Him better every day.
A reminder, please, only ask questions on the member's site, look at this comes from their
announcement, homepage of your member's site, and discontinue emailing questions.
In the past, we had a game, the ability to people to email and or ask questions or
be questions.
And we discontinued that actually about six, maybe seven, eight months ago now, but some
people just keep doing that.
And I understand if they feel like they're in a crisis, but we have to stay safe with
everything that's happening with the boards these days, and we just, where we get in trouble
is answering email questions or doing one-on-ones.
That's where we can get in trouble.
So that's why we do the Zoom calls, that's why we've added a second Zoom call in the week.
So please ask your questions via the Zoom call and discontinue asking questions via email.
And then remember, you have free access to all your courses, all the other courses I keep
reminding you about that.
We are going to have other courses.
I'm going to have an auto mute course.
I'm going to have a shorter mushroom course, which probably won't be done until January.
Okay.
There is a longer question.
Try to figure out why I started out with regular bowel movements before I started with the
problem.
And now I don't.
When I got my diagnosis and went mostly keto and then started on a parasite cleanse, I had
no problem.
My bowel movements were much better.
When I do have trouble, usually about 220 milligrams of magnesium at bedtime work.
And that didn't work.
I'd used aloe counsel, so yes, those are the best.
Now neither of those things work, and I'm having to rely on it and set a team.
So I'm going to stop there just a second.
So set a can be great, but it can cause some issues because it does work by stimulating
peristalsis, which can cause quarantine.
But other, if you can stomach the crampied literally, there's nothing wrong with using
it.
So if you're noticing that your bowel movements aren't nearly as good and we may want to relook
at your diet to see if there is something that's causing some issues of can be inflammation
in your gut, it can be that you're detoxing.
So if it is that you're just detoxing it, dump it a lot of stuff and you're got that, you
know, it's not necessarily a bad thing, but we need to be making sure they're ready to
have fiber to get things moving.
So do I'm not familiar with the aloe ferox product itself, we use the super aloe 250 for
more than molecular that we have private labeled phase 6 assist, I think it's going to
be a lot of that is, and you can certainly up the dose that I don't know how many milligrams
of the aloe is in that.
It's a specific aloe that helps with constipation issues, it's not just aloe on the
results.
I thought the daily animals would help improve my bowel movements.
Yes, no, you're not doing animals to help your bowel movements, you're doing animals
to stimulate your parasympathetics.
So sometimes doing daily animals can throw off your bowel movements, so that's a little
less nowhere that people have.
The purpose of doing daily animals is to stimulate your parasympathetics for help with detoxification
and stimulation of your immune system.
The only difference perhaps is I'm not drinking water since I had to get a freaking tea before
I started my own histamine diet, I was drinking a lot of green tea and rubles tea, which
I can't have now.
So this unspectrum pot, even though that's extra fiber, it doesn't seem to work either.
It did give it to you partly from the fiber, so that is a purpose of it.
Do I need to try something else?
I know the set is harsh.
Now I would up the aloe, I don't know what the milligram doses of that is, but typically
we start with 250 milligrams of that aloe.
So some of the aloe products out there only have like 50 milligrams, so you're way under
dosy possibly.
So look at that product, and then compare it with the super aloe to 50.
Some people take a couple of those a day, so they're taking 500 to 700 milligrams of
that aloe, so I don't know what the dose of that aloe fair is.
While doing all our research, we ended up talking to a competitor who seemed to have pretty
good machines, they were saying that arrived needs to be 300 or 100 to 300 megahertz to affect
cancer.
How many megahertz is the true right?
Is that what they said is true?
So with using frequencies, you can do different residents of a frequency.
So right back to that last question, the aloe leaf powder is a bitter extract.
So I'm going to remind myself about the super aloe, so hold on a little second, but I'm
going to pull up that product on my screen so I can answer that question there appropriately.
So is it, is it Cape Aloe?
So is it, it says, is it, is that what it says on the ingredients that this is aloe leaf powder
and bitter extract, 430 milligrams, so if it's not Cape Aloe, it's not the same thing.
So what really, so aloe leaf powder and bitter extract can be soothing on your gut, but
it's the Cape Aloe, it's the type of aloe, Cape C-A-P-E-A-L that you really need.
So really, but get the phase, it's called phase six assist, phase six assist, and that's
250 milligrams of Cape Aloe, start with just one a day because it will clean you out.
But it worked really well in the past because it was just nice and soothing for your gut.
It wasn't really for the purpose of really cleaning you up.
So we have never had anybody where the Cape Aloe did it to work.
So in my book, The Seven Faces of Detox, I also list that in phase six, because that would
be a phase six product, that's why it's called phase six assist, which is moving stuff
into the toilet, and I would highly recommend the Cape Aloe.
Okay, back to the frequencies.
So there's different residents, so literally you, so doing a different megahertz, the frequencies
that RIFE used were anywhere from 10,000 hertz to over a million hertz.
So that's what Royal RIFE used at the time.
You know, he had used different lots of other frequencies too, but that's one of the things
that some of, remember, most of RIFE's writings were destroyed.
They were taken and they're gone.
So but what we have left is some little pieces of his work of what he used.
So you are getting these frequencies, especially the higher frequencies in the footpath programs.
So his BX2 frequencies, so RIFE believed that cancer was a virus, and it was the BX2 virus,
what she called, and that's what she was killing to destroy the cancer.
Well, that's what he just believed at the time, it doesn't mean it's true, I don't think
it's true, I totally don't believe that that's true, but we still use his frequencies.
So everybody's program has those frequencies, and just because it might work.
So that's the benefit of having, you know, 56 hours of frequencies that you're doing every week.
So everybody has RIFE's ancient frequencies in their program.
So but plus, since, you know, the advent of RIFE technology, burgeoning back into existence
in the 70s and 80s, now we have a lot more known frequencies for specific cancers in all
of those are in your program, and those are very unique to the type of cancer.
So RIFE's original frequencies were not cancer, were not specific to the type of cancer,
and the current frequencies are very specific to the type of cancer.
So we have both RIFE's original frequencies and the current frequencies in your programs.
I would also be careful, and I know you were talking to a competitor, true RIFE,
probably prior to coming on board with us.
I'd be careful there are some companies out there that I've spoken to that you, you know,
I'm not loyal to true RIFE, I have no connection with the company.
I'm loyal to them, that it's the point that they've been, you know, very open and helpful
and they do everything that they can for, you know, our members.
But if there's another company that comes along that I think produces a better machine,
or you know, I'll switch it a heartbeat.
But that being said, I have communicated with a lot of these other companies,
and I'll tell you, you talk about classical shmuzer salespeople that are telling fibs
to their potential purchasers, you know, I call them, I've called them and pretended
that I'm just a patient looking for help.
And they just tell absolute, oh right, lies, you just gotta be careful.
There's a lot of, there's a lot of dishonest people out there in the world.
So, I'm there.
What two remarkable tests would you recommend for squalice cell carcinoma with a tonsil?
Like I have C-A-I-T-9, C-E-A, L-D-H, what's your suggestive timing considering I've already
started the program.
So you could run a, you could run all three of these, but the problem is that there isn't really
any specific tumor markers for squalice cell.
So the chance that these would be out of normal range is probably pretty small.
So there are certain cancers that tend to be, you know, that were, tumor markers tend to
be good things to use as markers.
C-A-I-T-9, typically C-A-I-T-9, 15, 3, 27, and C-E-A, and L-D-H can be positive with
breast cancer.
C-A-I-T-9 for sure can be positive with patriotic cancer, C-E-A, very common with colon rectal
cancer.
Squalice cell, cancer of the tonsil, many times we'll show any of these.
You could run them, they're not super expensive tests to run and see if any are on a range
and see, and then you've got to pick, okay, this one's even if it's smitten the normal range,
but it's, you know, at the high normal, you could use that kind of as a marker.
So even a lot, there's a lot of people with breast cancer that show no tumor markers positive.
So the tumor markers first came out, I don't remember when it was, but it was about 20 years
ago or so.
There was a lot of excitement to the oncology field that this was going to be a great way
to test and bother to care, probably they're just, they can be for some people, and then
they don't even show it for other people.
And then you're not even more complicated because if you're doing chemo, well, then it
controls all the tumor markers off completely.
So a lot of colleges won't even run them anymore because they're expecting that you're going
to do chemo, whether they wouldn't even use it.
PSA is the tumor marker.
So that's for prostate cancer.
It was listening to a Chris work video and he suggested not to run tumor markers test
once you've started a program, I would totally disagree with that.
I don't want to run tumor for test, the only reason, the only one I would agree with
that is if you're doing chemo.
So if you're doing chemo, your two workers can spike, and then it scares you.
I wish I had no net for I got started because I want to avoid invasive tests to check progress.
Do you agree with it?
So no, if you're doing a non invasive protocol, like a nutritional protocol, right, protocol,
et cetera, if you're not doing chemo, you can still run tumor marker tests.
So you won't get a spike into a marker test by doing a natural approach.
You'll only get a spike into a marker test, give you a false, you know, high false elevation
if you're doing chemo.
All these tests are read higher when you're killing off cancer, no, it only reads higher
when you're doing chemo.
As of now, neither by a college or by GP will run the tumor marker test for me.
So I'm going to have my chiropractor order and attempt to have my insurance pay for them,
or just pay cash.
They're not very expensive.
The lab core cost for running the CA 15, 3, 9, 29, 27, 29 at CEA is probably about 75 bucks.
You know, your chiropractor should, you know, pass on that savings to you.
What do you know about the frequencies of fabrics?
Is that something to pay attention to?
So no, I don't know much about the frequencies of fabrics and how that can affect us.
But I think you're talking about just how different things can cause negative effect to us.
And yes, there's truth to that.
All sorts of things can cause us negative effect, but I don't have not done any research on
that.
So I'm here.
The other day, recommended pectosol C for additional help detoxing catalytic.
You mentioned one to two scoops per day, but there are four pectosol C products on your website.
Because there's one specifically for heavy metal detoxing, but it's not a powder.
It's capsules.
So there are four products that have pectosol C in them.
So what is metal exitergy, and then one is the same thing that is our private label of metal
exitergy, which is called phase zero assist.
So that is specifically for is it specifically for detoxing heavy metals, well, the name is
metal exitergy.
Yes, no.
So it is just help support a key lady pathway, what I call phase zero.
So no, the metal exitergy would be a fine choice that that would be a fine choice, too.
But it has some other things in it.
It's one of my favorite products for chelation and helping pull metals and junk out of your
body.
I think in the in the zoom call, I just happen to mention pectosol, pectosol C is a is we have
that in a powder form as well, and then we have pectosol C in capsules as well.
The metal exitergy and the phase six assist are the exact same products again, and those
are capsules as well.
You know, you could do I mean, if you're doing a smoothie and you want to just throw a powder
and you're smoothie and you're sick of swallow and so many capsules, I think I would just
do the pectosol C powder.
If you're like, no, that doesn't bother me, I'd rather swallow a couple extra capsules
and I'd take a couple of the metal exitergy slash phase six assist or excuse me phase zero
assist.
The same thing that has metal ex has pectosol C in it, but it has some other key lenders in
it.
Could you discuss the difference between the two rec supplements I have been taking a supplement
from Kukuma Longa, which apparently needs pepper added to make an eye available.
My functional doctor said this is not as good as the full matrix turmeric, which you carry
in your store as to marrow clear.
Is there that big of a difference should I make the switch?
You recommend turmeric for me, but did not make a big deal about switching to the full matrix
product.
So I'm wondering if it's a big deal.
The difference between the full matrix or the molecular did a bunch of research on using
full spectrum turmeric.
And I have all in favor of using whole food products because there can be synergistic effects
with other pieces in the whole food that make that what is called the active ingredient
turmeric, which is curcumin, can make it more effective.
So we use a lot of the two world clear, but we also use a lot of our curcuclear.
So the curcuclear is not a full spectrum product.
It is the active form of curcumin.
There's benefits to both, but I want to get back to the adding pepper.
So a number of years ago, they found that adding black pepper to curcumin and other products
help you absorb it because if you just do turmeric powder, it's not going to be as readily
absorbed.
The problem with adding pepper, positive to adding pepper is you do absorb more of
the turmeric.
The negative is you absorb a lot more stock pepper, increases the absorption rate of anything
that's in your gut.
So then they found that adding pepper to a product, increased the absorption rate of metals
and stuff that were in your gut and toxins that were in your gut.
So most reputable supplement companies took pepper back out of their curcumin products.
So most reputable supplement companies, not all of them, but most of them do not contain
pepper in their curcumin.
So we don't recommend that you use curcumin with black pepper anymore.
We used to have benefacted probably got a video out there about using black pepper with
your curcumin, but that has been kind of not debunked because it does increase the absorption
of problems, increases the absorption of everything.
So I personally use curcuclear and tomorrow clear, and I kind of alternate them.
I don't, I take, sometimes I take actually our liposomal curcuclear now.
And so we got that product, we'll even increase the absorption rate much better with the
liposomal curcuclear.
So I just finished that effect.
I looked at my table here just this morning and thought, where's my liposomal curcuclear?
Oh yeah, I finished that last week.
I was actually going to go downstairs and grab another bottle of it.
That has become my favorite.
I think the better results with the liposomal curcuclear.
That's a chat question.
Just to follow up on the yellow and the pharynx did clean me out the past to the point where
I was taking a half capsule.
That's interesting.
Try to, I'll try the cape yellow as you suggested.
I noticed that the foot bath water has turned dark instead of the coppery color.
So maybe it is the detoxing that's making my unusual calcucution.
It's ineffectively can't be so if it is getting dark, you are definitely detoxing this for
sure.
All right.
Three other questions.
Well, then we covered everything.
We'll be back on Wednesday, so I will see you in two short days.
All right.
Love you all.
I'll be praying for you.
Thanks again.
Bye-bye.